[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE SUTTON: I'm Wayne Sutton.
MELINDA EPLER:
I'm Melinda Epler.
We're the founders
of Change Catalyst.
We empower inclusive and
sustainable innovation
globally.
Welcome to the series
sponsored by Women Techmakers,
Google's program that provides
visibility, community,
and resources for
women in technology.
Together, we're
helping tech hubs
to develop more inclusive
cultures, programs, and spaces.
WAYNE SUTTON: Studies show that
diversity and inclusion efforts
must come as a mandate from the
top in order to be successful.
Leaders set the values and the
culture of the organization
and determine the
measures for success.
MELINDA EPLER: The first
step is for leaders
to personally believe
diversity and inclusion
are right for your
organization and to drive
this home to your staff.
In order to do that, you need to
align your diversity inclusion
efforts with your
business goals.
WAYNE SUTTON: For instance,
how would diversity
affect your market growth,
improve product service design,
and develop
disruptive innovation?
MELINDA EPLER:
How will inclusion
affect your staff productivity,
customer satisfaction,
and overall profitability?
WAYNE SUTTON: How will
a diverse staff better
attract, educate, and support
a diverse tech population?
MELINDA EPLER: As a leader,
you must continuously
advocate for your
organization to be inclusive.
This means you have to
get uncomfortable and be
self-aware of your own biases.
Leaders must be empathetic to
differences and to the barriers
under-represented
people in tech face.
We call this leading
with empathy.
WAYNE SUTTON: With leadership
comes a responsibility
to bring diverse voices into
your decision-making process.
It's essential for leadership
to advocate for the company's
diversity and inclusion
and for leadership
to be diverse themselves.
First and foremost, create
a pathway for current staff
to become leaders in
your organization.
Also, offer
leadership development
pathways for future leaders
to rise in your organization.
MELINDA EPLER: Ensure your
promotion policies and salary
compensation are equitable
across all groups.
And when doing an
executive search,
you might want to
institute the Rooney Rule,
so that you're viewing
diverse candidates.
WAYNE SUTTON: Embed diversity
and inclusion strategies
into your succession planning.
MELINDA EPLER: Some
organizations also
develop a diversity committee
or inclusion advisory board.
You can read more about each
of these via the links below.
WAYNE SUTTON: If you have
one, your board of directors
has an important impact on
executive leadership, role
models, accountability,
and decision making.
Carefully consider the diversity
of new members of the board,
in order to develop a
diverse and inclusive guiding
body for your organization.
MELINDA EPLER: You might
also consider associate board
memberships.
Usually, these are
non-voting members
of your board of directors
or advisory board
who bring a diverse
perspective to the table.
We've created some specific
templates and resources you
can access via the links below.
WAYNE SUTTON: Lastly, just like
as your product development,
the most important piece
of diversity inclusion
is to start somewhere and then
continue to improve and grow
your efforts over time.
MELINDA EPLER: We've just
given you 11 different ways
to lead on inclusion.
WAYNE SUTTON: Start
with one today.
And what would that one be?
MELINDA EPLER:
And then, join us,
as we go deeper into cultural
change, external programs,
and physical spaces of tech
hubs in the next videos.
For more information
about Women Techmakers,
Change Catalyst, and additional
resources, see below.
WAYNE SUTTON: Share this
series with your community.
And let's work together to
create inclusive tech hubs
around the world.